foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hello
it's been so long
we're having some audio technical
difficulties
with a Yoshi that we're we're figuring
out here
but we're back we've been gone for three
weeks
oh
and we're back
um you're welcome
um you're welcome yeah we're gonna be
late because this is free so this is
what it is everyone welcome back
yay
this is our weekly q a we do here live
streamed on
the podcast
and we already got we rolling deep in
here already
well Salu in here Carol Freeman Mookie
susta
Andrew Lapointe Magdalena six light Dash
yo we deep in here
what's goody everyone
where's what's goody
goody
what's goody
so when Yoshi jumps back in
we're um
we're gonna do a little audio test and
then we'll see what's goody in the
hoodie on that end
yes we've been gone for three weeks
but we're back
you're welcome
you're welcome we could have quit we
could have said you know what why do
these live streams every week
and I still don't have an answer for
that but
beyond the fact that I love you
so
we do it
All For the Love of the Game
and the love of y'all and to help out
however we can
so I see oh yes Jones said the new
mustache and the five o'clock stash yes
it's coming in I just started it
last week so this is a little under a
week right now
um
but I had one back in the dizzy
and then I went on a trip with my wife
and had a shadow going on and I was like
oh that would be interesting so when we
got back I shaved everything but the
shadow
so we'll see what happens here
let's see
let's bring Yoshi in here
Yoshi
yo yo
no
um are the buttons highlighted did you
hit like 1 and 48 V
and all that funness
are those lit up
they're lit up
I can't hear you
oh
and you know Yoshi I was telling them
before you got back on here you know
that I don't know why we still do this
um
besides the love of them and the Love of
the Game For the Love of the Game
so did you hear me now oh my God that
that mustache is haunting me
this live stream is haunting me I am
I am one one technical difficulty away
from
this being over
hold on hold on I will say uh I have not
seen this mustache on camera and it's
check one
not uh not great yet
hello hey hold on hold on hold up hold
up hello hello
hey can you hear me now there it is
there it is
there it is you did it
yeah I just had to press a whole bunch
of different buttons
[Music]
the mic is there
yeah yeah we did it we did it look at
there look at God
it was that much that said hey I want to
be seen today by everybody so ahala at
the magical the you brought up the
magical mustache and then your
microphone started magically working so
there's something to that there's
something to that oh yeah
oh but sorry we're late but it's free so
deal with it
we're back after three weeks of Happy
[Music]
we are back I'm excited dude
you're excited I'm glad
yeah me too
yeah dude
oh yeah
I can see it on your face I'm great
where's where's my gin where's no I'm
kidding
I'm just kidding
um but yeah this is gonna be awesome
I'm super excited we've been gone for
three weeks
yeah I went on a bit of a family trip
family trip I love that it was delicious
it was all the above
you know what I think is so it's so
funny and this is just a reference right
this is just a is that every time you
say family
and I don't know if this is just me or
other people I keep thinking like it's
like a big trip with a bunch of people
but there's not a word for someone who's
married who doesn't have kids like you
don't call that person that typically a
family
no
no a wife having a husband and wife is
not a family
yeah it's usually a couple
because I think family couples aren't
married couples are dating
no couples are married too
don't don't project your no no no no I'm
not your family
tribalism on me a family's in the eye of
the beholder so I probably
say family so
so I want to ask the people because when
I think of family
I think family is a
either someone with kids or a group of
family members
a husband and wife team
which is I never think of as a family
but just because you don't think of it
doesn't mean it doesn't exist no no I I
get it right which is which is the
reason for the conversation right I've
never so every time here's the thing
when you say family when you say family
every time you're like oh I took a
family trip I always think your in-laws
are with you when you say family I never
think just you and wifey
are on that trip so every time you say
family
it's like a group of people that have
kids or they're going with like their
siblings or somebody so when you say you
take a family trip
I know you went with your wife and and
you but in my mind you went with the
in-laws every time you say a family trip
so family isn't just husband and wife
and and the reason I'm bringing it up is
I'm just trying to think and did I miss
something in reference to what a family
is
well
what do you call it Mr omniscient Family
Man a couple a couple I went on a
couple's trip
no like a couple trips I went on a
couple trips I went on a trip with my
wife like or like but I I think I'm just
maybe it's just me but I don't think of
a family as a husband and wife team
like so for example somebody asked a
question is a honeymoon count as a
family trip
yes but then octo
Chia said no wait no he's he he did not
wait someone was on my side where'd it
go
someone was on my side did they wait
where'd it go
either way
I think a family is what you make
and if if I mean my bad I didn't mean
this was so taboo me saying no no no
it's it's not a family
as soon as you say it
I automatically think that you're with
the wrong thing
okay yeah then you're with your in-laws
or you're with extended family
it's never oh just Joel and wifey
that's what I mean so like you say
family I'm like oh look at look at Joe
hanging out with his in-laws
again right so every time you've said I
go on a family trip I'm like look at
John Joe must be close with his in-laws
just bringing it all together going on
these trips
and the the sad thing is the only person
that is defending me said I'm married
without kids and think of it as a family
but then the very next sentence is scary
time to have kids don't want any chance
of Biden kissing them
so the person that's defending me
completely negated the defense
kissing his children
wow okay all right so it looks like
people are saying Yoshi's right
foreign
and I don't want to come off like I'm
I'm just I'm just expressing the way
that I have thought of the term when
people reference it like if you take a
family trip
I think it's not a bunch of people in
the car that is just husband and wife so
when you say I took a family trip like
I'm literally thinking there's a a lot
of people in the car
okay well no we um and sometimes I also
think you took the dog with you because
I know why people do [__] like that you
know
right yeah so I guess I should clarify
it wasn't a family trip because we went
to England and
and
um had a very lovely time
without any
maybe we had a maybe it was a liberated
trip maybe it's a family trip is when
you're
you're confined to
having to do what other people want to
do but we did whatever we wanted so for
sure for sure
um just to rub that in I don't know if
you remember the last time you got to do
whatever you wanted whenever you wanted
to whenever you're you and your wife
could just pack up and go to Europe but
um that's very true that's so true we're
we're a modern family we're a modern
family for sure absolutely we have the
hot breath family here you know that's
that's who we
yes and with all the data
out there we're all family at this point
we are all a family
but if we took enough like 23andMe test
I'm pretty sure everybody in a hot
breath would be related somehow
big facts
are good almost Jefferson
yeah that's a really good um
start of a comedy q a where we have
people asking like hey what's your
advice for getting on stage for the
first time and we're like but first
family trip
which
coincidentally your first time on stage
will not be a family trip and if it is
it will be their last family trip to one
of your shows
um so you have that to look forward to
oh yeah
that's funny
oh but then all right
but John yeah I mean you know family
okay
well hold on
hold on let's Google family
and we're going deeper and let's Google
family because we all have ADD
[Laughter]
a group of one or more parents and their
children living together as a unit
I mean Google's does say a family is a
group of two or more persons related by
birth marriage adoption who live
together so yeah I mean it's technically
family
yes yes so technically
yeah
this is irrelevant to anything but in
the Merriam-Webster Dictionary it says
consisting of two parents rearing
children
what was the other definition from
uh that was one I posted that's that's a
that's actually just a government site
so actually it's not even real
oh
so the government's not real now you see
what kind of leadership y'all are
following how breadthiverse you all
voted for Yoshi and he doesn't even
think the government's real
so yeah oh yeah I mean right or wrong
now so Miriam Webster basic unit
consisting of two parents rearing
children
the bees definition is spouse and
children the number two definition group
of individuals living Under One Roof
and under one head a group of persons of
common ancestry
a group of people United by certain
convictions uh or a common affiliation
which is what we are we're a hot breath
family mm-hmm
yeah I mean
have I don't I didn't think I was crazy
you know what I mean right no people are
people are people offending you
yeah people are agreeing with you yeah
so yeah yeah so I don't know I'm not
that we needed to start off with that it
was just I was just sharing a thought
as you mentioned your family trip how
was your family yeah
don't worry about it it's the family
trip was non-existent because it wasn't
a family trip apparently apparently it
was just
it was just a a luxury I guess it was
just White Privilege I guess is what
y'all would call it
uh hold on I'm gonna try to
try to set up a mic stand here because
this is already
whatever
I like the dynamic that you move with
your mic and I just sit with it in front
of me you like that
yeah
she's just full of good ideas today it's
full of them
[Music]
yeah
somebody said family is 15 or more
priests is a fried chicken
that's true it is a family meal oh that
was Andrew little Point yeah
Sasha said what's the deal with families
[Laughter]
so um I mean that's very valid though
yeah
if I heard someone say family I would
probably assume
[Laughter]
now that I've come full circle
how about that how about that how's that
feel oh that looks good dude that looks
awesome
wait hold up let me angle it this way so
it looks like
oh
[Music]
this will be for the bloopers we'll have
a blooper reel of just Jewel making fart
noises yeah this whole episode is just
one blooper reel
laughs
so the family trip is good
yeah it was all good yep everything was
everything was great
how long do I stay
we were there for
two weeks nine ten days nice we traveled
around went to some flower shows and
such
so it was really based on our itinerary
it was more like a retirement trip is
what it sounded like
more than uh a family trip or a couple's
trip
I think this is fascinating I think
couples that that travel together it's
always fascinating so did you have an
itinerary itinerary for every itinerary
itinerary for every single day that you
were there
oh yeah we had a Google map and we had
everything yeah it was attached to the
itinerary was attached to the Google
Maps every single day for where you're
gonna go where when when's lunch when
y'all do certain things all the way
through it was pretty well mapped out we
were for sure we were fairly flecked
we're more flexible than we had been
mm-hmm but I mean we knew there were
certain things we wanted to go and see
but when we did them we were a little
more flexible on
for sure okay
but Lucy asked about flower shows what
are flower shows that was going to be my
next questions so
oh is it like is it like going to Pikes
and just staying there is that what a
flower show is or is that different
no this was the rhs Chelsea flower show
which is probably the biggest flower
show in the world
where people travel from all over the
world to see it and then we went to the
Cotswolds and went to a bunch of gardens
there
and
um yeah
oh this is next level call Cassidy
no this was Next Level we've been
working towards I mean you know we've
been training for this moment
we've been training for this moment this
was our Super Bowl this was our Super
Bowl of flowers no it was huge man it
was crazy it was like it was legit like
Woodstock for flowers it was crazy
wow so do you uh were there specific
ones that you wanted to see or is just
the collection was what y'all were all
about
specific people's like displays we
wanted to see yeah yeah yeah yeah so
there were people that we wanted to see
there they're like displays there but um
I don't know I know it was a lot of fun
I just don't care about this
[Laughter]
I'll tell you this not that this matches
it but uh I got stuck in uh
I got stuck in Louisville after I came
back from the contest I was supposed to
fly out uh
uh Sunday night but I went earlier to
try to get like on a flight earlier so I
got the earliest one just to try and it
was like a 7 A.M flight
well as soon as you switch tickets
you are now on that ticket you can no
longer get on the other flights but that
flight had mechanical issues
flight had mechanical issues so it's the
plane is not going anywhere basically
what the way the pilot described it the
starter was no longer working I was like
yeah y'all should probably not take that
up wow so uh so this is Delta so Delta
says oh we can get you a hotel for the
night I go to the hotel
and it's uh what is it
um
it's a modeling show a modeling show and
I have no idea what that is at the hotel
but
I thought it was like At first I thought
it was like uh What's that show
um that happens in Atlanta
uh during Broner's Brothers No during
Ludacris's weekend during uh
the nerd show God not a nerd show oh oh
Comic-Con Comic-Con it was like to come
I thought it was like Comic-Con
because I saw a lot of shirts that were
very like
artsy and uh but it's a modeling show
and it's the people that do models for
movies sets and different kinds of stuff
and it's the model of like
um like ships aliens all that stuff so I
go into it and somebody just gave me
their like little uh
somebody gave me their badge and next
thing you know like it's the coolest
stuff
and I see literally I was like here's
here's how I know it's it's some Next
Level nerd stuff I can't how many black
people are there so out of the 500
[Laughter]
.
well played well
I was trying to relate to your flower
show
that was the point of that oh but
obviously that did not work but it was
oh so you were saying like count the
black people yes so how many black
people did you see there
oh I don't see race I just which is
usually means there's nothing
I honestly don't even I I can't imagine
a lot for sure
you would have noticed if there was at
least one
no there were deaf sum
okay all right so more than one
but I mean honestly when I go into
places
and it's all white people I I notice
more like if I go into places I was like
there's a lot of white people in here
like I noticed that more than like a
diverse crowd a diverse crowd I just
kind of fit right in but
it's all white people but I'm sorry
about this majority white as the planet
you know as that region of the world
would dictate you know
but
um
but yes okay all right cool
yeah yeah it was cool
and you counted all the black people I
did there were four total
yeah who let them in
I love you know what all right it's like
there were four and they were the
janitors uh
uh and then it was just Yoshi
no I'm just kidding
that's how I get canceled
you're for sure but it was great though
it was the stuff that they had were like
very cool
but I mean I must like a Star Wars Star
Trek um I'm into like all that stuff so
it was lots of models of that of like
ships and R2D2 was there it was Oh Oh I
thought you meant like model like
modeling oh like toy models and stuff
yeah like oh nice yeah yeah toy models
of like
ships of like Star Trek and Star Wars
and different kinds of shows oh that's
okay that's cool yeah it was very cool
sounds like yeah I never even heard of
that before so when they said models
I thought what you thought
right it's a modeling show I was like
yeah it is right right because you
weren't on a family trip so you were
ready to
Daddy's unsupervised daddy's gonna let
loose a little bit he's gonna have some
pinot and go to the model show
[Laughter]
see if he can get an only fans discount
code so Shirley temples and get down it
was great
that's funny
but yeah man well welcome back to uh
this side of the pond as they say thank
you thank you and welcome back hot
breadthiverse too we back in here
we're sitting at 18 deep
and we haven't talked about comedy at
all so that's pretty solid and we didn't
really promote this either this has been
all comedy to be honest with you no
that's a good point yeah it has that's a
good point
that's a good point
but um
yeah we do want to answer your questions
yeah um
oh is irritated Sasha said his irritated
hairy lips
lighting Yoshi flower show Joel a
character you're working on
because this is gold
hilarious
that was great that was very funny
that was fun because in my mind I was
like yeah I probably need to work on
this I probably need to cut it down
there's too many words I'm not getting
to the punch line you know normal but it
does that does fit your like Suburban
dad character so you know there is if
you were trying to make it a bit it does
fit like your persona you know what I
mean oh for sure yeah yeah I mean the
HOA black dude
six days old
gotcha and I'm going I am going on a
family trip this weekend we are going to
see my in-laws
and it's Father's Day weekend so we are
doing a family trip a real family trip
it's a real family trip for sure so I'm
really hoping it
fills out between now and then I've been
like hold my breath trying to make
everything push out my lip you know how
you just
no really hoping that makes it grow more
I didn't know that was a technique
but I haven't
um it fills out though like I used to
have one and it was it was super legit
so you had you had one when you started
right I did have I had one when I
started yeah and then Louie Anderson
told me
he used to he used to have a mustache
and then he shaved it because he didn't
want to be just a mustache
gotcha because I told him the story
I walked out on stage one time and
someone just goes mustache
before I say anything it's like the
audience stops clapping and then someone
just goes mustache
and then I told I told him that story
when I was opening for him and um
it uh
and he was like you know I shaved mine
because I wanted to be more than just
the mustache
and that show
I learned to ask for pictures after that
show I didn't ask for a picture I only
asked for a picture if I work with
someone I didn't ask for a picture
and I I don't I don't have regrets but I
wish I do wish I did on that one
um because I was hosting and I bombed I
was so new to Comedy and I bombed and it
was like a makeshift stage in like the
ballroom of a hotel and
it was very not sturdy and he goes up
there and his opener is if I fall it's
not planned it's like call 911.
but I didn't ask for a picture and I
regret that because I and I had the
stash I was too cool I had a stash you
know so
but we'll see I may end up shaving it I
don't have any plans for it Beyond like
oh I haven't done this in a while it's
just something different you know for
sure yeah
you know everybody posting these clips
how can I stand out maybe it's a Mustang
maybe this is my Matt Rife ABS maybe
this mustache is my matte rifabs people
start seeing clips of me and they're
like mustache
and that's what
you should open every single one of your
Clips as mustache and then go right into
your bed it's a logo I mean if
I mean we will do things for likes you
know what I mean
if I can monetize if this mustache
monetizes we're we're going all the way
in there's gonna be merch
money money
myself believe it I am I am not a purist
anymore I will pull every parlor trick
in the book
whatever it takes nowadays
but it'll fill out it's a little it's a
little janky right now but it it does
fill out
um so you guys are seeing the early
stages
Okay it definitely
is noticeable
but it just looks dirty right now
I mean it looks kind of dirty it classes
up it gets classier
it does
it does yeah yeah
okay
it gets classier
um I guess it's classy as a
a stash can get
you know how classy that is oh yeah
classy stash
[Music]
I feel like your noises
[Laughter]
are the audio representation of you
wiping the wall
yeah for sure that's exactly what it is
that is exactly what it is actually
it's a good point
that's a really good point
um I love it oh here we go
you got questions yeah
oh
um
I was just gonna I don't know why
there it is there it is look at that
there it is
so that's what you all have to look
forward to
it I'll tell y'all I have to look
forward to oh my God somebody just sent
you a Super Chat let's go
wait where's that noise
we got a sharehorn for Chris send a
super chat
so the mustache grow fund
you know be really cool
here's the thing Joe
I noticed the Mercedes as the first
thing it's so I can't imagine when
people see you from the stage so
somebody's saying mustache is not
surprising because as soon as I saw you
okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
I didn't say it but I was like it's a
there's a mustache right there
yeah it really it really changed the
dynamic in the room it really shifted
the energy
oh my God I think it's I think that's
why I mean Louie Anderson basically told
me to shave it and then I did and I felt
great and then I'm growing it back
because I want to be famous
yeah and this is my this is my Hail Mary
[Music]
[Laughter]
that was a mustache
I mean I can just literally see Joel and
then a mustache and then buyers come
right underneath it is a shirt
I mean Jeff Foxworthy I'll take I'll
take I'll take half
of what Jeff Foxworthy has for sure for
sure I mean probably 10 even 10 yeah
half even 10 is a livable foreverable
that team's done it all man I don't care
you know there's always going to be
haters and whatnot that dude has done it
all and he brought his friends along for
the ride so yeah
yeah aspirations
yeah Jeff is like oh you did it like the
right way and then notice it your way
no like
nothing in the Press like you know good
Family Guy like nothing it's like oh
damn
super prolific
super prolific yeah
huge fan base like just
a guy shows made a card game incredibly
nice
yeah super nice guy you know someone
he gets enough shine
but that dude he has like multiple books
multiple specials like
he he bakes bread I mean he does a lot I
like he just dropped a new book and I
was just like looking at his like resume
like good night I don't know if he gets
enough
I mean he's very rich and does very well
for himself he tours theaters he's doing
great but it's like you never hear his
name come up
you know what I mean of like a great
like one of like people say like oh look
Brian Regan's my favorite clean comic or
Jim gaffkin but like Tom is Tom Papa
clean actually now that I
no he's not oh okay
you know and but I mean as I said
Italian I haven't really I haven't
watched any of his specials so there is
that yeah none of them you haven't
watched a single time Papa special I
haven't watched a single Tom Papa
special and I just brought up how he
doesn't get enough shine and I'm not
even Shining
the Tom Papa's Netflix specials are
legit and he's like I love
I mean
he just sits and just tells jokes he
doesn't move he doesn't do voices these
are just straight up jokes dude yeah
yeah he's legit
man's doppelganger just
[Music]
yo mookie said he got a Super Chat to
help Yoshi get his hairline back
bro
[Applause]
there you go
we can just mic drop on that that's
Yoshi's hairline is on my upper lip
that's where it is right there
it escaped
it needs a new home can you grow can you
grow a mustache what if we both grew
mustaches oh my God absolutely not like
it goes and it stays as a fuzz so it
just stays fuzzy like nothing ever big
yeah yeah
that's hilarious dude most Dutch growth
fun and hairline growth fun that's
hilarious that's so funny
this is a good one to get back in the
swing I do
but we need a podcast for next week
excuse me I have a little flim coming up
I've been healthy and I'm expelling all
the sin for sure get it uh
but um so you're saying everything we
just did up to this point is not podcast
worthy because I'm thinking this is
about as entertaining as it gets I mean
it's pretty visual though we're talking
about it doesn't fit does it fit the
pocket like if people are logging on to
Spotify or apple and they're like oh hot
breath this week can't wait to learn
about comedy and then it's us talking
about whether or not a family is real
that's and then a mustache that they
can't see
oh yeah you know what they're gonna do
after they hear somebody talking about a
mustache they're gonna go look up that
mustache and they're gonna be like we
get it even if they
if they make it this far into the
podcast after about 20 minutes of
deciding what a family is I think people
would have tuned out
so dude I mean what do y'all think uh
watching this live what are the people
watching live think
y'all are fans of the podcast you come
for a certain reason would you listen to
this on the podcast
[Music]
40 minutes of this that's this is what
we've done 40 years I mean they're here
we started late we're gonna get it yeah
that's what I'm saying this is the
podcast like we're just chilling at this
point
we don't have to teach on every podcast
right you're right you know something
interesting and I do have a story about
a show I did this weekend that I I have
to say before we get out of here
um but
I will say something interesting I've
been seeing comedians out and about
and like when I when I I think we talked
about me going to Austin before my trip
my family trip and um I met a lot of
comics out there that were fans of the
show and a lot of them have been echoing
this where they're saying I listened to
it for a while
and then like they like got the
information and they're like okay this
is how you do X Y and Z and now they're
out there doing it so they don't listen
anymore
so we gotta figure out how do we get
these get these Comics back
because like they love the show they
loved the value they got and now they're
out there like grinding applying it so
it's almost like we need to we need to
diversify the content here we got to
figure out more
um
we just find more content about family
mustaches and white people stuff yeah
this is our biggest episode I'm gonna
I would be thrilled actually
because then we can monetize
and yeah
grow mustaches
but I have to get to this show I'm gonna
stop talking about monetizing I've just
been on a family trip you know and
that's
um a lot of uh
monetize talk
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh for the culture that's cool I didn't
realize Verizon accepted clout as
payment that's really cool
[Laughter]
um
um I mean the people have spoken dude
people are like yeah this is podcast
worthy okay okay okay well
yeah cool I know we have some questions
you want to get some questions or you
want to talk your story I wanna I wanna
hear your story though
yeah
um
let's let's do a few of these questions
okay and then we can close on the story
that'll be the closer awesome but let's
set a timer on these because let's keep
it let's keep it rained in here but we
appreciate you all for hanging out with
us
yeah on this live stream we do every
Tuesday tell your fellow comedian
friends
you know share this show that's how we
grow so share this with your fellow
comedians if you're out on the scene
and you're talking about comedy be like
yo have you heard hot breath
share this show that's everything you
need to know about comedy so share the
show you know hit like on the YouTube
video leave a comment let's let's get
this algorithm going y'all all right
we've had fun
all this free content is great but yeah
for almost a decade
I'm ready to quit so
I've got other things you know I'm
trying to do a career here I'm trying to
get out on the road I'm trying to post
crowd work clips and go viral
so if you enjoy all the freeness you're
getting all you gotta do is share it
help us out
For the Love of
Pete
[Laughter]
yeah for the love of the mustache nah I
love doing this and I love you all and I
appreciate y'all sure like just hit the
like button guys just hit the like
button right right
it's something so here we go let's do
the timer and let's get into it here
um six light Dash
asked how do you guys write your
material when basically every joke has
been done already
well you just put your point of view on
the joke topic that's how you make it
your own Yoshi and I are both married we
both have married jokes every basically
every comedian that's married does how
you make it not hack and not like anyone
else as you tell your own personal
experience your own point of view on
marriage talk about things that only you
can talk about based on that topic and
bada boom the jokes have not been done
already
mm-hmm yeah I echoed that sentiment just
from your perspective even if you like
even if you're not married or like it's
not that you can't talk about family
stuff but you can talk about family
stuff being
not married if you've seen something but
it's about getting your perspective out
there so uh yeah just from your point of
view is the key
boom
yes indeed
um we could have saved 30 seconds there
uh Yoshi repeating what I said
uh
um let's see
fasting Nomad said just did my first
stand-up gig and immediately got booked
at an arena things are going well
congratulations yeah Bravo
that's awesome
um
I hope I didn't hurt your feelings there
are you okay you just leaned back did I
hurt your feelings oh okay these are
jokes
no you just want to make sure
yeah
your mustache offended me your words did
not my mustache is very offensive for
sure
it's a whole different it's a different
vibe it's a different vibe coming in
it's very different
I remember when I when I had it grown
out and I shaved it the first time
people would be like you look like your
son like you look like
because it's totally different Vibes
yeah
I mean
I don't know how to say this but like I
was just thinking because I could hear
my like my kids in the background and
I'm thinking to myself can I introduce
him to Joel no I can't
hilarious
I become the next Mr Rogers and I just
have a mustache she's like hello drone
hello kids
[Laughter]
um
where'd it go
there oh
one second I saw a few more questions
near the end here I was trying to scroll
we've had so much engagement the live
stream which for listening to the
podcast you got to join us on the live
stream every Tuesday at 5 PM Eastern
Time
alvado asked how do you deal with the
nervousness of showcases slash important
shows
hmm
foreign
I always feel like nervousness is just a
part of being a performer it's going to
be there it's a matter of getting
yourself into a routine of what do you
do to combat that nervousness for me I
always remind myself to have a good time
if I'm having a good time then I know
that the show is going to go well if I
don't focus on not having if like if I
get too much other stuff in my head then
I'm not having a good time so I just try
to tell myself have a good time and then
that helps me get into like my best
space
yeah so the nerves are gonna be there
and that's normal but what helps me is
the more prepared I am the more
confident I am that despite being
nervous I'm ready for this showcase or
important show so just making sure I
have my set list that I'm rehearsed that
I know what I'm gonna do just going in
as prepared as possible gives me that
confidence to overcome those nerves
for sure baboon
uh and maybe just one more here
is what I'm seeing
uh in six light Dash we just answered
your question about the material
earlier
I was scrolling I didn't see them there
was a lot of like
what is a family and questions like that
oh John Shaw asked what's your advice
for doing stand up publicly for the
first time that kind of ties into
what we just said with Alvaro but this
could also be advice on finding a show
which is Google usually pulls up
something
yep an open mic ask somebody who's
already done comedy uh uh hopefully you
are not doing comedy like super cold
where you don't know enough well you
don't know another comedian I'd say if
you can find another comedian that does
it do that most people in any scene have
a Facebook group or like a place to go
to see the list of where to do open mics
a Discord something there's something
out there that lists Reddit has a list
of different mics across any city scene
yeah and it helps also to go to the open
mic First Once you find one go there
first and just watch get a feel for
everything if you liked a comic there
talk to them after be like hey you were
really funny nice job just compliment
them as a great Icebreaker
um but going to an open mic first can be
a way to ease into it if you don't just
want to jump in
for sure
yeah because you lost fantasy football
yes exactly
which is such a great punishment such a
great punishment
um
uh zaynova how do you typically like to
start the first 10 seconds on stage
first 10 seconds
um
I think probably the biggest thing is I
try to make sure that the audience
understands who I am or some kind of
identifier of what they're about to get
is actually very helpful so something
that helps them figure out what the rest
of the perspective of your set is going
to be like so I I usually try to start
my setup either telling people I'm a dad
I'm an immigrant I have kids I'm married
something so then they have some level
of how the rest of these jokes are gonna
go yeah just look at it as like a first
date so you just want to open up with
something very introductory I mean
sometimes in the first 10 seconds I'm
just like hi I'm Joel type deal like I
just kind of give them a nice feel for
how I'm going to be talking and like my
overall Vibe and you want to get to a
laugh within 20 seconds that's usually A
good rule of thumb is you want to get
your laugh within the first 20 seconds
but you know ease into it like a
conversation like a first date you just
kind of want to ease into it and then
build from there
yeah and um
yeah there's um
I was trying to think of a like
Jason Roland who we've talked about on
here before he does like a comedy
feedback course where he helps people
kind of figure out how they want to open
and build their sets and stuff who we
worked with when we did
our type 5 accelerator so I think he is
about to do another one which I could
not I couldn't recommend Jason enough I
mean I talked to him before I did like
my dry bar special to get the set ready
so he's definitely someone if you're
looking to make an investment in your
comedy I would say he's a good one to
get that one-on-one coaching
um
you can Google them or you can DM me if
you'd like to link or I can put it in
the
description of the podcast as well
because he's a he's a he's a fam of the
pod
yeah he is
and uh VP of World Series of Comedy as
well it's very cool
um
Chris has are you going to do the 100
contest again
at some point
um I don't know when though but yeah we
used to do that every single month
really during the pandemic
we would do it once a month but then it
just got yeah you know doing this live
stream
is already
it's all ready if it wasn't for Yoshi
just know
I love y'all but my wife is waiting
my family is waiting she wants to go see
some flowers yeah no
I love doing this but yeah you just kind
of kind of
I'd rather do fewer things better than
get stretched too thin and then have a
meltdown and cry on the live stream like
I did one time during the pandemic so
we're not doing that
uh which did happen for sure oh no I
remember it 100 happened yeah yeah you
guys go live for over 400 days in a row
and see what happens
it's a good experiment it's a good
experiment y'all go live
for over 400 Days
um
oh yeah and Carol keto Carol said yeah
Jason is doing the course he has three
spots left
very nice yeah I'll put a link to that
in the live stream and if you guys do uh
he has like a discount code for hot
Brethren as well
very cool
um
uh
speaking of crying
um
Magdalena said I've my social anxiety
has gotten kind of bad but I miss
performing are there any places you'd
recommend
online to phase back in or I just need
to get back out there
uh definitely there's still
um I think I forget what this community
was but there's a community of people
that still do online remote mics uh I
think honestly there might be one like
almost every single day still oh wow
that are just zoom mics uh as well and
they do you know set reviews and all
kinds of stuff so that's still out there
if you don't want to phase back in also
say if you don't want to perform like in
front of a bunch of comedians maybe go
do like a mixed mic that's not just
comedy that's other stuff as well and
that way you don't have the pressure of
trying to be funny around comedians
you're just saying some stuff into a mic
just to see how it feels and that might
be a good way to phase it back in
yeah for sure I
lavoom nailed it
um
as usual as usual you nailed it right
there I mean I only had 10 seconds so
yeah you really hogged all the time on
that one so I was just
just moving on
um
[Laughter]
you can tell we haven't been together in
a while
we're back baby no this is we're back
we're back it's all love
oh it's our love of course
Chris S asked starting out oh and this
may be Chris
who we were um
we were talking on uh the Facebook he
was messing me about
I'm glad you could make it there um let
me get there Chris Chris said in
starting out
one-liners are a good way to go from and
Chris is someone who I think probably a
lot of people can relate to of like he's
done it once
and now he's trying to like make it
perfect before he gets back up type deal
you know so he like he did it once and
it went okay and now he's like oh well
let me get it all right before I get
back on stage when in reality it's kind
of like you kind of need to get on stage
to work it out in a sense like you right
off stage but to actually know what's
worth keeping
and what is good you you have to do it
on stage or a zoom like we were just
saying as well the more you get on stage
the better it's gonna be if you're
waiting till you get like the right
words or the perfect set as anyone would
call it you're going to be waiting a
while because the stage is the truth
teller the stage is the place that you
know if something worked versus
something didn't work so even let's say
you improve one bit get on stage try
that one bit out with the rest of
wherever you know if you want to call it
your crappy material sure but you
approved on that one bit and then the
next time you improve on two bits next
time prove on three bits like it is a
step-by-step process it's not just all
of a sudden magically gonna turn on you
and that's the beauty and comedy it'll
keep you humble real quick there's many
moments where I'm like I'm on fire next
day I eat it and I'm like back to Earth
baby and then I just keep going up and
that's comedy
right there yeah I mean literally like
the number one advice through all the
podcast interviews by far the number one
piece of advice is you have to get on
stage like
at the end of the day you you have to
get on stage that's that's really where
you learn what's worth keeping what's
not how to deliver a joke how to say a
joke at all
it all happens on stage now writing off
stage is very important but if uh if
you're not on stage then you're just not
ain't doing it kids and I I don't want
to be
harsh but that's just the reality
of you know
developing as a comedian you got to be
on stage as much as as much as possible
yeah so let me get to his question but I
think that's something that I think a
lot of
especially a lot of
hot breathers out there are either
thinking about getting on stage or they
got on stage and now they're like
hesitant to get back on or the next
steps and stuff but it's you just kind
of start ugly and just kinda build it up
and it's going to be bad and just know
everyone's bad I think that's our advice
earlier was like even if you go to an
open mic just to watch it and realize oh
everyone sucks like
if you're scared to get on stage I think
just going to an open mic will give you
a little more confidence like oh well I
can be bad in front of other Bad Comics
and you're gonna have one or few things
that maybe pop and you're like oh yay
and you can kind of go from there or you
may kill your first time everyone has a
different experience with every show
but it all comes down to getting on that
stage so
stage time
to not to your uh question on there
Chris uh and starting out one-liners are
a good way to go from what I have
gathered
all right let me start over
uh
is it a question or is it advice no it's
a question it's a question and starting
out one-liners are a good way to go from
what I have gathered however many tags
what however
all right in starting out foreign
oh okay so he's basically saying from
what he's heard one-liners are a great
place to start
however how many tags do you add off of
these jokes or do you just
do one-liners without tags
um if you're just starting out I'd say
add at least two tags
and have that in your back pocket if
you're just starting out just try two
tags
um the good thing about one-liners is
yes you can get that laugh but if you
don't have any tags
as the audience is hearing it and let's
and they laugh at a punch line you're
now giving them a lot of space before
they laugh again from your next
one-liner so if you give them a tag you
give them a chance to actually laugh a
couple more times before you start your
next joke so just remember that you want
to try to keep them laughing for a good
amount of time so just try two tags
that's that's my advice two tags to see
what happens
yeah and if you can't think of any tags
then just do another joke as well like
not every joke you may find great tags
for or it may take months to find
another tag for the joke but if you find
a really good one-liner just do that one
and then move on and you just build it
literally joke by joke
yes
but I do I mean one-liners are a great
place to start I mean I did one-liners
exclusively for this first several years
of my career and just kind of built it
out from there
but it's it's all very incremental
it's all very just joke by joke show by
show
but you're on the right track I mean
you're writing you've been on stage you
have the mindset around okay oh I know
how to write jokes or I I understand
jokes are important and also adding tags
to them so you're thinking in the right
direction now it's just putting it into
practice yeah I always say here's I
don't know if somebody has said this but
if you tag it they will laugh
um
yeah that's a yoshiism right there right
there
they won't laugh or they will arrest you
if you're tagging public property you
will get arrested for doing that
um
but
that's not on us we can't be an alibi
look at you
look at that I mean I I I'm I should be
a comedian or something like an improv
whiz like that just came out of damn
just you know I mean just it's just a
simple Association you know it's just
it's just the simplest of a remix of tag
being interpreted in two different ways
just the fundamentals
um which I do talk about in our online
course that Chris is currently in as
well
punch lines oh for sure
bow
oh
[Music]
all right we're down to our last few
questions here but I wanna I wanna tell
my story let's get to these
um
I don't know that one huh
we'll skip that one there's no need to
even say those words
in solely the stream so let's get to the
story Okay so
um
I Joel the mustache buyers
all right
wait
there it is
so I I did a church gig this week this
weekend it was a church fundraiser
clean show obviously and I didn't
realize
I forget how much comedians struggle to
be clean like I met I met a comic when I
was out in Austin who said he turned
down
a a 500 Church gig to do 10 minutes
because they want him to be clean
and he couldn't do it five hundred
dollars and it was opening for a bigger
Church comedian who is like a family
friend who he could have gone on tour
with
so I asked for his info in um in
replacement I was like oh yeah I can do
that 10 minutes 500 bucks
but he couldn't be clean and I forgot
and like the comics before the show all
funny experienced Comics were like
nervous about like oh this is clean and
they were asking the host like how clean
is clean and what is cleaning all this
like
people people were freaking out
beforehand about like how to be clean at
this church gig so
a comedian and this was the this was
actually the uh the final coming of the
evening
um
he he dropped
GD
at this church gig he said GD
yeah the gosh darn uh the but in the
biblical he didn't say it in the
biblical way he he dropped it and yeah
he's he said it like on autopilot like
he literally it's almost like he was
doing his joke and didn't even think it
looked like he didn't even realize it
the audience
gasped like they they everyone like
audibly went they all like pulled back
but he just kept going so they like kept
going with him like oh the set kept
going they kept laughing but the pre the
the pastor was in the back and he like
he was like looking around he was
looking at the host who the host was
someone who helps out at that church so
like he knows everyone there and they
were talking
and then
he
I can't believe this but then he said
the p word
the ho-ha word rhymes with wussy
oh wow
and at that moment he got the light
early and the pastor was back there like
giving him the twirl like wrap it up
type deal
and like what was interesting is when he
dropped GD people
were concerned but then they kept going
along with him which was interesting to
see like he didn't start bombing after
that and then he dropped the other word
and I talked and I like I I like as soon
as he got off
like one of the commands dapped him up
and like you know other nice job I was
like dude you just you said it's like
you you swore up there and he i s he
goes I swear to you he said what you you
I don't want to say the word because I
have a mustache and it comes off here
but he's like what you can't say wussies
what is it he's like he's at a church
fundraiser
and he's still
was like wait you can't say wussy's here
what
it was unbelievable
like I've never seen anything like that
to where like I could see the GDs which
is the worst word to slip at a church
event but it just slipped and he kept
going almost like he didn't realize it
so him and the host and him talked after
so I don't know what was said but it was
literally like
20 minutes set clean church fundraiser
GD may have slipped but I feel like he
intentionally said like wussies like I
think he was like oh that'll be fine
here this is totally cool
so it was just very eye-opening
of just how difficult
clean comedy is and how much more I need
to start charging for clean comedy
yo this is a specialized this is like
organic all right this I'm getting
you're getting free range
pasture-raised
non-GMO organic comedy here like yeah no
wussies no Wick no well whiners nothing
none of that like I didn't realize
Comics really struggled with being clean
so much and I'm not I don't care you do
what you want up there but at least
being able to be clean
for a a little while gives you way more
work opportunity for sure yeah oh wow
um yeah that's interesting here's here's
here's the thing that I've recognized
about some Church not church gigs but
like even just like clean gigs
is that they'll let you go as long as
like you're funny
and you don't
cross the line but obviously the p word
is definitely crossing the line
like that's so over the line like
there's not a like the fact that he said
you can't say wussies is that was the
most shocking thing to me
than the GD because actually the GD it
sounds so weird but like GD and I've
heard Comics say GD
in a church thing like oh really yeah
yeah I've heard it oh dude like
Cardinals that's the other thing is that
you also don't know this is what I what
you also do don't recognize is that
there's some churches that are like a
little bit more relaxed they're like
okay with some commentary about like
other things not all churches are the
same
yeah I mean because there's some
churches that are just like they'll tell
you hey
no sexual references not even innuendos
like nothing about sex nothing about uh
drugs or nothing about I think what's
the other one or nothing about religion
basically like you can talk about church
but that's about it so like you can't
get into any or political that's usually
what it is and then there's some
Churches like oh yeah just keep it clean
don't say bad words and then you can
talk about anything and everything as
long as you don't say bad words so and I
think that's what a lot of comedians
always ask is like how clean is clean I
always do like PG-13 and I'll tell them
hey this crowd does not like this type
of material when I know
um but yeah that's interesting
yeah you got to get on that church
circuit if it comes that natural to you
buddy like
you gotta wrap that look at me
yeah Pastor out here but I didn't I just
didn't know yeah I mean everyone's
definition of clean is different
and like a joke
everyone did 20. everyone did 20 got it
so so I went up first don't don't ask me
why uh
but
not my problem uh I mean you said you
said a high bar
yeah you do want to open up the show
like uh like you're set you wanna yeah
you wanna open up strong but to end
that's how the show ended
talk about an arc
but um
but I mean everyone did great and um he
still did great despite all of that so I
mean it was fine and I talked to the
pastor afterwards and I was like I'm
really sorry about that and he was like
I thought it was going to be livid and
maybe he was like with the host or
whatnot that booked it but with me he
was like no I understand this is out of
y'all's comfort zone and that doing a
church show is different from what
you're used to so I understand things
happen but like I I was like bruh okay
yeah yeah
yeah there's definitely going to be a
committee meeting afterwards for sure
that was that was the last comedy show I
will yeah maybe uh no it's totally fine
we'll just never do this again yeah yeah
we're gonna go back to you anyone who
can sing Acoustics uh guitars and
singers for sure yeah
that's how you know that's how you know
that a club has tried a comedian before
because they'll be like oh yeah yeah
we're gonna we do clean comedy at this
and then a comedian comes in and does
not do clean and then you're like yeah
we're just gonna do Open Mic no comedy
kids we're doing a children's Open Mic
yeah sure yep yep okay yeah so I mean so
that was the story it was from the from
the weekend so anyone listening
holler at your boy for any clean comedy
needs
we'd plug Shawty we are here in these
streets yeah pushing pushing clean it's
like that push and pee song but we
pushing clean we push and clean hey
yeah so college boy
no P words
we keep it well you can't say that he
was literally like you can't say that
yes yes
all right we can land This Plane I just
found that
to be baffling
uh
but
whatever y'all want to do go for it hey
for you know I don't tell anyone what to
do or not to do up there so it's your
time
so yeah if you want to book us
you can message us
all that funness
yeah we got a show in two weeks dude
it's gonna be lit in Charleston right
yeah yeah that's awesome that's very
exciting
yeah
uh which was booked through the hot
breadthiverse so
any peeps out there
the book shows reach out to us you know
we'd love to talk details and see what
we can make happen
hit us up on Instagrams Facebook
and we do clean PG-13 I mean we'll do
rated R and just have if you want you
know what I mean I'll go hard for the
price uh you know if someone's to pay me
to be dirty
I'm with it
what if somebody just books themselves
it's just not I just do dirty I don't do
no clean just dirty I'm just a dirty
Community yup I mean there's people out
there that do that for sure oh my gosh
yeah and they're millionaires like you
know there's there's people yeah
it's kind of like just finding your own
way find your own voice like we were
asked earlier about how to do jokes when
they've all been taken it's like it's
putting your spin on this comedy game
and just trusting your instincts and let
that lead the way unless it's swearing
at a church show
uh well gosh darn gosh darn well I think
that's it what do you think yo so you
think we've done it all
hey I I feel like uh I mean could I be
here for another two hours so I don't
see my kids I could but
but I have to go see my family
so you got to go see your family you
gotta go go check on some flowers you
gotta go check on the dog you got you
got man you got responsibilities dude so
but we love you all so much absolutely
next week bye y'all bye
[Music]
home